la chili 2 ou vivre 1 français de choix
de vie pas toujours facile moi je
voulais je dois te battre chaque jour
pour garder des talents et garder ta
fierté des francophones
j'ai moi ça les universités françaises
formé au sol en français et je veux
continuer qu'une ma vie en france ces
quinze longues qui domine dans la cour
d'école en guerre ou en anglais parce
que quand tu commences des conversations
en anglais c'est le stum d'avis à la
fesse conclure par moment où 5 nous nos
enfants sont différents par jour et
parfois c'est lourd à porter indifférent
le combat recommence chaque matin en
sortant de la maison et bonne journée
[Musique]
dès qu'il monte dans l'autobus scolaire
les enfants adoptent l'anglais à elliot
lake
la proportion de francophones a chuté de
moitié depuis 30 ans ils ne sont plus
que 15 %
l'anglais domine dans la cour de
récréation et dans les corridors même à
l'école française c'est qui compliquait
de japon en français même si c'est une
école francophone parce que tu veux pas
te faire juger par les autres lors de
son ouverture en 1969 l'école georges
vanier accueillait près de 500 élèves
depuis les mines d'uranium ont fermé
aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus que 95
enfants dans des classes à moitié vide
le groupe de 5e et 6e année ne compte
une douzaine d'élèves
[Musique]
la journée commence avec l'hymne
national suivie de la prière
[Musique]
en ontario les écoles publiques sont
encore sous un laïc soit catholique
on montre les valeurs catholiques donc
ça c'est très très important pour la
population francophone on célèbre nos
succès catholique et francophone à
chaque fin de mois
j'invite mes fait raser à mieux aider à
remettre des certificats aux élèves qui
ont démontré la vertu du parent dans le
lien entre la langue et la religion est
encore très fort file station guillaume
d'aou on remet des certificats
soulignant les efforts en français et le
respect de valeurs catholiques
je sais que j'ai fait quelque chose de
mal je peux même aller jusqu au point de
parler avec le single en ontario 70% des
enfants francophones fréquentent des
écoles catholiques la religion à aide à
préserver la langue
d'après vous oui moi je pense que c'est
très important
oui car si on regarde nos ancêtres c'est
tu es chrétien qui sont venus dans le
pays donc s'installer tout partout et
puis ont fondé des églises êtes du liban
vous avez vécu en france un peu est ce
que vous vous considérez franco-ontarien
aussi oui je suis très fier de l'être
aussi
[Musique]
quelque chose est ce que nous voyons en
toile ou en aunis clé on s'appelle on
fait car notre cap dans la classe de 3e
et 4e année les élèves préparent un
calendrier de l'avent
la plupart de ces enfants auto ou deux
par anglophone qu'est-ce que vous êtes
fier d'être à parler le français
oui quoique ans une petite minute avant
de me répondre
pourquoi c'est important pour toi parce
que si je crains un anglais m'ont fait
un buzz the trick or de la maison mais
pas si je marque jamais rompu pourquoi
parce qu'elle aime franco arabe en
anglais conçu qualité longue c'est pour
avoir les stocks jean paul jobs comme
mine d'oak racing en plus inquiet des
troubles et il est presque mort il me
parlait français s'ils comprennent 10 le
français
je voulais mettre sa soeur élève
d'elliot lake ont manifesté contre les
compressions annoncées par le
gouvernement de dog folle je trouve que
c'est important d'avoir beaucoup de
serveurs français comme l'université que
ça je continue mon chemin en français
[Musique]
la journée de manifestation
5 heures j'avais reconnu beaucoup
d'anglophones qui voulait une université
française ces choses ça m'a fait chaud
au coeur
chez les dames où l'indignation s'est
transformé en militantisme
on a vécu un recul avec monsieur ford
mais en même temps on a en a un regain
d'énergie de voir le drapeau qui
flottait à l'assemblée nationale j'en ai
eu les larmes aux yeux
c'est formidable l'appui qui nous est
donné c'est pas les plus beaux sapins et
des sapins moi ça fait chaud au coeur
mais je pense qu'on commence juste une
lutte c'est vraiment pas fini
je pense à vous désirez vraiment
plusieurs mois c'est pour plusieurs
années cette lettre
[Musique]